este puente concentra las esperanzas de
miles de emigrantes al otro lado el paso
texas es la puerta de entrada a eeuu
cada día decenas de familias lo cruzan
pero no en la dirección que esperaban
acaban en ciudad juárez una ciudad
mexicana que no conocen volver a casa o
quedarse aquí para todos ellos el
fracaso de no cruzar es un reto un reto
que eric un cubano de 41 años superó con
éxito expulsado tras intentar cruzar la
frontera el año pasado está a la espera
de la resolución de su solicitud de
asilo mientras tanto encontró un trabajo
como mesero no es eeuu pero para él es
mejor que nada ya que cuenta que un
profesional un profesionista en este
caso gana 30 dólares al mes
aquí usted puede bajar 30 dólares en
tres días y fuera emprendedor y quisiera
salir adelante honradamente pudiera
hacerlo aquí - la jefa de este
restaurante de emigrantes que buscan
trabajo temporal todos los días entonces
pues casi todos nos relacionamos porque
pues casi todos somos migrantes
todos tenemos pasado entonces la llamada
de eeuu también deja a muchos mexicanos
a la deriva estos hombres viven en la
calle son expulsados de la hera trump
vivieron varios años en eeuu antes de
ser expulsados aquí estamos todos muy
cerca de la tierra prometida y nos ponen
más trabas o sea nos detienen más
ya nos quede en la centroamérica todos
esos no tienen hacer lo político y como
tienen problemas de su país nos aceptan
para ellos quedarse aquí no es una
opción y todos piensan en intentar
cruzar la frontera ilegalmente de nuevo
tengo que regresar
tenemos que buscar el modo
de vez en cuando el truco viene a comer
aquí debido a la pandemia muchos centros
han cerrado o limitado en su capacidad
este lugar es modesto es la casa de
rosalba bernal la cual transformó en un
refugio con los medios que tenía a su
alcance el albergue se hizo precisamente
ver nació por el kobe y se y se abrió
por esa razón pero después a las
autoridades legal pues tuvimos que
cerrar unos mesecitos pero si éste las
demandas subieron y subió mucho
el apartamento compartido de eric esta
noche hay fiesta vive con otros cuatro
compatriotas todos en la flor de la
juventud al haber llegado solos aquí se
integran fácilmente
esta noche estamos festejando lá
despedida 1a
d
de un amigo está esperando su llamada
por la parte de acnur que va a pelear su
caso de asilos políticos en los eeuu
norteamérica que va a celebrar con
mojito seguido lo celebramos
es la llamada que cruce había estado
inspirando durante más de un año puede
irse mañana su solicitud de asilo
depende del protocolo de protección de
migrantes está política e instituida por
trump lo obligó a permanecer en méxico
durante todo el proceso gracias a que yo
va a ir en la revirtió puede pisar suelo
estadounidense con donna throne novia
esperanza nada con mayor aire así la
inmigración tiene esperanza y es este
soplo de aire fresco el que sigue
trayendo a miles de familias de
centroamérica pero el ser arrestados cae
como balde de agua fría al ser
expulsados por medidas sanitarias y no
por normas migratorias ni siquiera
pudieron solicitar asilo están en lo que
hemos llamado algo así como un limbo
migratorio tienen la oportunidad de
decidir ellos mismos si sus hijos y les
contó lo que les conviene o nos interesa
es regresar a su país
esperar tal vez aquí sobre todo para
aquellos casos de personas que no pueden
regresar a su país hay quienes este para
quienes no es una opción regresar a su
país si lo sabemos este es el gran día
para juste
se le espera en un centro de la onu para
realizar una prueba de cobisa pasa sus
últimas horas en línea y tengo con mi
papel aquí mpp pero estoy muy muy muy
orgulloso del señor presidente bueno que
no haga esa facilidad porque hemos
esperado que tengo un año año y nueve
meses aquí esperando pero bueno la
espera señora su familia lo inspira en
miami donde espera empezar una nueva
vida
aparte que soy cubano soy muy trabajador
trabajo en cualquier cosa lo que haya
que hacer y no voy a hacer una carga
para eeuu
solo hay unas pocas docenas de personas
como jose que cruzan la frontera cada
día es un número pequeño pero es la
esperanza a la que se aferran todos los
migrantes en busca del sueño americano